nous parlons politique à présent dans
cette édition du 7 8 nous sommes
toujours en direct si vous me suivez
entre 18h et 19h j'accueille antoine
baisse bonsoir vous êtes adhérent à lui
dit vous faites donc partie de ces
jeunes engagés dans cette formation
centriste de jean louis borloo et demain
il y aura le lancement de la fédération
des jeunes udi des yvelines ce sera à
versailles plus précisément à quoi va
servir cette section jeunes de l'udps et
y ait une formation déjà à la base aussi
très récente ans elle a été mise en
place au 1000 septembre 2006 tout à fait
alors la fédération se structure petit à
petit on santé parmi les jeunes des
différents mouvements jeunes existant au
sein dudit un besoin de se constituer de
se fédérer pour pouvoir agir est vrai
que récupérer le la dynamique qu'ils
hissent au niveau national et la craie
au plan local
est ce que vous êtes nombreux justement
jeunes engagés au sein du pays
on a laissé les nombreux c'est un
mouvement assez porter la dynamique qui
se crée depuis quelques mois est assez
importante je fais assez moi même
surpris avec mes amis du nombre
d'adhérents en direct puisque à lui dit
nous avons les adhérents qui font qu'ils
sont déjà adhérents au nouveau centre
parti radical aux constituants aux
partis constituant de lui dit il ya
aussi maintenant les adhérents directs
et ceux là sont assez nombreux week
combien d'adhérents aujourd'hui à lui d
ea a lui dit précisément je peux pas
vous dire département on est une bonne
cinquantaine et vous avez les gènes
cinquantaine chez les jeunes tout au
total au total eon ces jeunes justement
c'est la première fois qu'ils s'engagent
en politique où ils ont déjà connu
d'autre part d'accor avait en fait ça
dépend l ump on n'a pas besoin
quelques-uns ont quitté l'ump pour venir
avec nous c'est pas une vague immense
mine à quelques uns c'est assez notable
ce qui était déjà dans les partis
constituant du 10e ont une activité
antérieure
et puis donc quand vous essayez et
nouveaux adhérents dit judy direct que
comment sur l'implication maintenant et
vous avez un soutien forcément de vos
aînés arnaud richard qui est déclassé et
coordinateur udi pour le département il
ya aussi le maire de louveciennes andré
van holsbeeck
cependant si tu es en densité majeur
aussi voilà le maire de buchelay par
exemple ils attendent quoi de cette
section jeunes ils attendent quoi des
jeunes qui s'engagent à lui dès hier
soutien britannique fait être aussi les
municipales surtout les européennes les
municipales c'était voilà tout à fait
les ongles 2014 ça sera une année
importante pour lui dit notamment sur la
question des européennes
ils attendent quoi une dynamique un
soutien une innovation au niveau des
idées c'est important aussi c'est un
labo les jeunes aussi donc ça permet de
réfléchir ce nouvelles problématiques
qui se posent une vision particulière
parfois de la société que non pas nos
aînés donc voilà c'est un stimulus
comment se positionne lui dei par
rapport à l'ump
aujourd'hui l'ump aujourd'hui jean louis
borloo le président est assez clair nous
avons des idées un croc puce eu un
carton
qu'en dire nous avons des idées des
principes fondateurs ils sont clairs
pro-européen plutôt fédéraliste
clairement contrairement à l'ump mais
ump est notre allié naturel au second
tour c'est comme ça que le propose jean
louis borloo je crois que c'est
important de souligner notamment pour
les municipales sachant que plus d y
aura une indépendance forte de par ses
idées plus l'indépendance se répercutera
une également au niveau des votes parce
que vous auriez souhaité quoi que jean
louis borloo s'affirment plus par
exemple sur les présidentielles plus
récemment qu'il se présente et qu'il
s'affirme qu'il affirme sa différence
face à aujourd'hui c'est difficile lui
dit et un mouvement jeune est ce qu'on
peut avoir le sentiment que le 10 et 1
c'est un outil en fait voilà pour le
premier tour mais que de toute façon au
final mais je crois aussi que les gens
sont relativement un patient qui vous
laisser le temps aux partis de se
constituer aujourd'hui si je suis là
effectivement c'est aussi par pour
parler de la fédération qui se crée
c'est une dynamique qui existe au niveau
national pour laisser le temps lily de
se positionner de créer ces fédérations
de laisser venir les membres
à nous tout simplement et pour que cela
puisse se répercuter sur le plan du
terrain pour au niveau des actions à
partir de ce moment là effectivement la
dépendance comment sera la plus
importante sur les sujets d'actualité
par exemple comment se positionne udi
sur la question du mariage pour tous au
sein de l'ump il y avait des positions
plutôt portées contre eux je crois que
la position du dignitaire a été assez
clair aussi une liberté totale de vote
on entendait chantal jouanno sur france
2 il ya quelques jours elle même le
mettez en avant lui dit c'est une
liberté de vote
certains étaient pour certains étaient
contre je crois qu'au contraire que
c'est assez important de laisser la
porte ouverte à toutes les idées on est
là pour discuter pas pour imposer un
thème ni une idée par quelles sont les
premières actions de la section jeunes
de l'udps et qui la fédération des
jeunes qui va voir le jour demain ça
leur avait remis la réaction pour
l'instant la fondation se fait peu de
temps avant les vacances donc l'action
durant juillet et août sera certainement
relativement minime mais de la rentrée
ça sera créé une dynamique mettre en
place et les élections puisque
aujourd'hui c'est une fonction un
fonctionnement collégial donc mettre en
place ce fonctionnement avec les
élections
et puis petit à petit bain portait
effectivement vous disiez en classe les
élections municipales pelé préparer les
européennes et vous serez candidat à ces
élections municipales on vous retrouvera
sur l'une des listes dans le débat du
reflet tout à fait sur la bulle de verre
offert une position nous verrons c'est
encore à déterminer exactement vous
reviendra sur pato à cette occasion
merci à vous